[Music]
hey there party people welcome to the
honest trailer commentary for the
kissing booth one
and two yes the only two movies that
matter
uh we'll be talking about the honest
trailer going through it with you
explaining our deep personal
live journal thoughts about it uh
sharing with you our hot slash
speaking of which there's joe and lon
hey guys thanks for joining me
hey you were the only boys i would want
to be in a kissing booth with
blindfolded or no oh no blindfold just
pure eye contact
unbroken eye contact it's most romantic
if you start blindfolded and then you
take the blindfold dramatically off i
think that's what we need to do your
eyeballs we literally touch
i don't know uh so we're going to do
that and then we're going to talk about
uh well we actually don't have any
outtakes so we have a we had a a
substitute editor this week where
our editor kevin is on vacation and he
did a wonderful job of the trailer but
there was a few things that we forgot
uh namely we've got to do uh comments at
the end of this
uh at the end sorry and we forgot to do
uh outtakes for this show so we're gonna
give you
uh next weekend's trailer is just going
to be comments and outtakes so i hope
you enjoyed that
it's just gonna be the cut jokes and
things we asked john
can we make the thumbnail like when they
do like captain crunch oops all berries
where it's just like a picture of you
like oops
all comments but we will take your
uh respond to some comments at the end
of this video and uh some things that
you
might happen to ask in the chat about
kissing what's it like how do you do it
what's the best way to practice
oh i'm going to pillows all the way down
the kissing booth you guys i feel a
little bad picking on this movie because
it's
uh written by a 15 year old and yet
adults were the ones who took that and
made it a new feature
yeah i i think maybe like we wouldn't
want to necessarily spend all this time
slagging a
a piece of fiction written by a 15 year
old this movie was not made by
these people are responsible for
themselves yeah and i think it's
it's open season on them not the
original author i don't want to go after
her
yeah totally and the the crazy thing
though was like
when i was watching these i was like
what
twisted like sick old like
40 something gross florida guy wrote
these things and then it's like
oh a 15 year old girl wrote them wow oh
that works
okay like it just it has the sensibility
of like
um a much older person trying to like be
cravingly
copying what the teens are into down to
like the bad boy who wears like a
leather jacket and rides a motorcycle
like that's a 50s trope
how is this a kid it's weird to discover
those hack tropes are legit i mean
a lot of fan fiction is i mean these are
the first sort of projects that a young
creative mind is sort of taking on and
and you know
when you are first starting out you crib
from stuff you've seen and things that
you know i mean every writer does that
that's not
fan fiction specifically so i think
that's what you're seeing a lot is like
the author saw that on tv or 90210 or
some other high school thing that lifted
that trope
and integrated it into her own world
which in fanfiction is totally normal
it's like
but isn't that the sort of thing you
like adapt when you're making it into a
movie
yeah instead of just bringing it in
wholesale and being like betty
you got it you gotta bring in the stuff
that uh you know
brought everybody to the party to begin
with like it was a popular
look we live in a world now where there
there are executives at studios and
streaming services that have to keep an
eye out on wattpad and like creepypasta
what like that's the post 50 shades
world we live in that
people are keeping an eye on fanfic
sites to see what's
in fairness it's sort of a little of
both there's also like wattpad is very
actively out there
trying to get adaptations of stuff that
blew up
because it makes their content a lot
more valuable
but you're not wrong it's like both
things are happening at once like
hollywood is like what are the kids into
fanfic and then wattpad is also like hey
you guys seen this fanfic come check it
out now is it not to not to split hairs
but is it fanfic
because it's fanfic is like it's an ode
to like another ip
right was this this wasn't like twilight
with the names changed like
no i don't think this is this is just
another ip this is just a story that was
published to
wattpad which is that site where are all
the fanfic i mean we're old what do we
know
so there's uh what really shook me about
uh the kissing booth one and this was
addressed in the sequel thankfully and
this is why i prefer
two to one lon um we're having that huge
schism on beyond like i thought kisses
like i don't think either is like a
great movie but
i thought one was a lot more first of
all breezy
and easy to get through whereas two was
like a ridley scott length
slog it was not oh yeah i'll be i'll be
perfectly honest by the time i got to
two
uh i left my body i mean i wasn't
i know i watched it that is fair i
watched both of these
in a row like i marathoned the kissing
booths
so maybe it was just fatigue set in by
halfway through part two
yeah i mean that is possible two things
struck me is one was the
lack of uh plot importance of
this titular kissing booth uh the fact
that the kissing booth
really appears once in the first movie
and is referred to
in making maybe a desperate attempt to
make the title make sense they're like
i guess this never would have happened
if it wasn't for that old kissing booth
but you could really say the same thing
about any scene
in that film yeah it's weird that they
get two
at-bats and neither time figured out a
way to actually work
the kissing booth into the story like we
gave you a whole second movie to try
again well it's super weird right
because it's like
let's compare it to say like uh another
netflix
young adult rom-com that's actually
pretty good which was uh to all the boys
i've loved before but filming it much
better much better the notes
these notes she wrote were crushes
they're the inciting incident
of the move like the kissing booth
should be like the first
well it should be called 21 simple rules
i have for my best friend not dating my
controller
25 year old playing a teenager brother
it's
that and that was the other thing i
wanted to talk about for kissing booth
one and why i found it so bizarre and
upsetting
is because they have all the makings of
like a love triangle like he's the ducky
he like
this this guy lee has always loved her
and
uh she just never they never saw each
other that way or she never saw him like
that she always had a crush on the
aggressive like violent hot older
brother
but he never that wasn't where they went
with it so it was really just like a
very possessive friendship
like that was the only tension keeping
her from dating this guy was like
but we have friend rules
yeah the the way they've gone with it is
basically
like it was oh like you're only jealous
or you only
love somebody until you can find like
somebody else like the solution for any
any kind of feeling like jealousy or
whatever is just oh date this other
person and that you know like that they
keep coming back to that
which i don't really think is very
realistic like even if you're with
somebody if you love somebody
like those feelings are much more
complicated than i think it gets
weirder than the second one yeah i
remember the second one
uh because it seems like everyone else
in the second one
sees it but them like his
very upset when she leaves a room
girlfriend is constantly just like
you two are in love with each other yeah
um
but they're but are they i mean this is
to spencer's point this is what i keep
coming back to
both movies are lee and
elle like do they really have romantic
feelings because at this point they've
never
actually conceded this and they've never
acted on them it's
i mean it's only the people like joe
saying the people around them are on to
them
but are they on to them or are they just
suspicious because they're so clo like i
can't i
actually can't feel i don't know what
the movies are saying to us look
we have to i'm sorry but like we have to
wait for part three where
they finally end up in the kissing booth
like that's the ultimate test
oh i mean i'm sure that the third is
the um neverending story the two
sphinxes that shoot lasers
complete with the confusing sexual
feelings that those statues gave me
maybe these are why rom-coms aren't
traditionally done as like three-part
shared universe franchises because it's
just like just get to it like
do they like each other or not man yeah
they're welcome
you don't need to end game this speaking
of just get to it let's not spend the
entire day
talking about the kissing booth list or
less
or less kind of let's
i'm sure we'll have much more to say as
we watch the trailer the kissing booth
i have so much to say i wonder what like
the
french and italian titles are for these
[Music]
movies
comes two films based on a 15 year old's
wattpad
that became smash hits thanks to a
demographic i've aged way out of
hey hey close on young lady my day movie
teens acted age appropriately
oh yeah that's better
the kissing booze pause
kissing booth in italian is kabina de
bacchi
[Music]
um probably a lot less scandalous in
europe because they just kiss each other
hello so it's like yeah
it's always like this is normal day at
school yes
all right keep going that's what you
call the front porch of your house
[Laughter]
the kissing portico all right keep going
get ready for an old-school rom-com with
all the hallmarks of a john hughes
classic
sexual harassment double standards for
women
that whole thing with like the first day
of school she has to wear
the tiniest skirt with her butt cheeks
hanging out and then the guy slaps her
and then she gets in trouble and then he
asks her out on a date by wearing a tiny
skirt
is really weird right and that's only
the beginning
then he stands her up for that date and
she thinks like what a jerk but she
finds out that
actually the older brother of her best
friend has been threatening
every man at school for years into not
asking her out
in this weird shadow campaign to win her
affection
it's like what is going on in this movie
i'm just imagining if i
was getting ready for the first day of
school at school uniforms and like
my my my jeans and underwear or whatever
completely ripped and like it was either
wear these ripped
uh pants with my balls hanging out or
find
something else to put on and i was like
no
i'll just wear these
plums they find so many dumb ways to get
her
out of her clothes all of them i mean
there's the boys the boys
yeah like it is a it is it's like a
relentless
campaign to get these kids undressed
and like look i think literally 25 i'd
be uncomfortable
yeah that's true yeah like they used to
do this i mean like american pie
plenty of nudity like all the way back
to porkies and stuff like that but there
was a certain
uh just like open horniness about those
movies where this one like
you could take out all that stuff and
it's still it's still like a disney
channel movie except people like are
suddenly in their underwear
that's interesting american pie was like
let's get laid
yeah i think that's what it is i think
you're right like this movie's like
but still as horny as those movies but
right
yeah i think that's it i think that's
why it feels weird it's also just a
clash with like
more modern senses but like those movies
from the 80s that you're describing
are gross like when you watch them today
like
we recognize that like that was gross
and weird and like
maybe the movies didn't need to be like
that like especially
revenge of the nerds is often held up as
like the the
alpha example of that but they're all
kind of like that and so
when you watch a movie that was made
today with otherwise very contemporary
tone and standards but then puts that
stuff
back in there anyway it does feel
jarring
right up to the nerds from revenge of
the nerds being in this movie
yeah i mean this there's a lot of that
sensibility like otherwise it feels like
a thing that
was created in 2020 but there is this
weird
mean streak and pervert streak from the
80s that like shows up every now and
again again why i thought
it was uh uh at least a 40 year old man
writing this so
right because in some ways feel like
somebody who came of age in that era
trying to like recreate it for today all
right let's keep going
double standards for women and there you
are treating some [ __ ] that you picked
up at the club
and molly ringwald as you journey to a
los angeles so white
you'll swear you're actually in south
africa because you are
it goes and gets into a fight on the
first day of school
great story now about those blood
diamonds
buzz the dads are south africa and uh uh
tuppen
definitely south african and uh the
maine
noah is i believe australian yeah
and the giant yeah toughens the giant um
and but noah spends the entire movie
like kind of in like a growl and i
realized like oh that's to hide the
accent
like yeah he kind of just says a few
things like this as he's turning away
it's a good way to uh to secret away the
accent but weirdly like
you know i'm
some of it was shot in los angeles which
is what threw me like they're definitely
on like the santa monica pier
at certain points and then which there
are though there is one there's one shot
where there clearly is an establishing
shot and they're really in santa monica
but then you get a close-up of joey king
walking along the pier and it's very
obviously a green screen backdrop behind
her so i feel like
they later did pickups in south africa
posing as real locations right but
you're right there was at least a week
or two
in l.a yeah you were in this kind of
bizarro world like like it was like
sliders that episode where
everything's the same except the golden
gate bridge is blue um
they're like close enough it was like
this is
not los angeles but it looks now it
looks like it now it doesn't anyway
i mean there's definitely like a uh
whatever a drone shot of them at the
hollywood sign
and like they did a week and a half in
la for sure
yeah um and the rest i guess there's tax
breaks in
in jobberg yeah then prawns
all right keep going meet elle
a high school girl struggling to escape
her inner monologue
in spite of what happened tonight i
couldn't stop thinking about what noah
said to me
who's voice over butts in every five
minutes like a netflix version of clippy
you obviously couldn't see this but my
heart just did a back flip
yeah that's what the acting is for never
great to hear your childhood crush say
it's super gross in your pants
look if i'd wanted to listen to this
crap i'd buy the audiobook okay
life throws curves at you shut up ugh
this is
all your fault kissing booth
set your lips to smooch when l is caught
between the flynn brothers
two dudes whose parents work in the
money factory
there's lee who builds a friendship with
elle based on 21
simple rules um just back to how rich
the flynn's
parents are um it really really makes it
messed up that
uh elle is like completely scrambling to
find a way to pay her way through
college
like that the second movie hinges on
like her needing to raise money to maybe
go to a private school
look where her best friend surrogate mom
lives
like they could find 50 grand in the
couch cushions there
that grant for a dance dance revolution
contest
well we'll get to that we'll get to that
everyone in this movie even because even
her house
i guess because it's supposed to be set
in la and i'm like that's a
pretty big nice house for los angeles
and she goes to school with all the
other rich people so
oh my god that's like jerry bruckheimer
or like a
cocaine kingpin's house right there what
else i think about their school
like 20 million dollar house she goes to
like
yeah she goes to like la los angeles
county day which is not a real school
but like obviously
is a prestigious like private private
squad uniforms yeah
like that tuition is like harvard
tuition like where's she getting
that money so when they're yeah when
they're suddenly like you have to do a
dance contest to afford harvard i was
like what
also as long as we're going there you
don't like as a senior
just decide one day like hey you know
where i'd like to go
harvard i'm not gonna look into that if
only i can afford it like
you've been getting rory gilmore did it
with yale
you got a you got a 1450 on your sats
and then yes yeah i mean noah makes
sense because
i figured noah was clearly like there's
a flynn library somewhere at harvard
like right now
yeah like it's a football scholarship
thing which i don't even know if
harvard's harvard have a football
is that like i mean they have a team yes
they do okay the ivy league competes
against each other in sports sometimes
it's definitely not their
most important thing i mean i guess
maybe they do but that's how they're
sort of explaining the noah
version but like you can't like she
would have to have had a plan from like
at least last year to try to get into
harvard
yeah harvard heart ivy league football
is um is all played instead of a
field they play in the large backyard of
someone's summer home
right and all right yeah it's very
kennedy's touch football touch football
right
uh okay keep going
there's lee who builds a friendship with
elle based on 21
simple rules rule number one only your
best friend
gets to know your birthday wishes no
matter how mad you are at your best
friend you have to forgive them
if they give you ice cream rule number
eighteen always be happy for your best
number six if you can't tell your best
friend about something you're doing
you probably shouldn't 19. always go to
the same school as your role number two
never share our secrets with anyone else
number 16. when your bestie needs you
there you need to be well number five
always do the thanksgiving wishbone with
your bestie
how was that number five how's that the
fifth
like once the rules were in place at
some point there was just a moment where
they had thanksgiving together and she
did that with um
like i don't know her little brother and
his little arthur fist just like
started he was like
the rules are where because remember
when we were first writing this
i i was insistent on the fifty shades
fanfic angle and the flynn brothers are
why i
think it's like a teenage fifty shades
because she sort of split christian gray
apart
one of them is all the controlling rules
and then one of them is the horrible
abusive manipulative uh
romantic interest you're splitting two
pretty boys
hmm tricky that's a lot yeah yeah the
rules are
that's an insane number of rules for
somebody that you're friends with
um to have wait what did it look like
when they made those
like was it the same scene as 50 shades
where they're just across a long table
and it's just these two
they're just like eights here's i
believe you look over this contract
rule number five thanksgiving wishbones
there are a lot of rom-coms that are
fixated on this idea of like a couple
that
met at like age four and then like grew
up
and fell in love and like they're the
only people they've ever been in love
with and it's like
it's a weird idea to think about in
practical
real life like i don't know any couples
like that who
were best friends at like age five and
now we're married
it is weird but it's not movie weird
which is why i kept expecting
them to be in love with each other um
right no
in a movie it's like a movie trope i'm
just saying like we never really
questioned that trope and like seeing it
here you do get struck as like
you know you meet a lot of people in
high school they should maybe just
broaden their horizons a little bit
as we were talking there were like five
five named characters in this movie
everyone else is like
the nerd yearbook guy braces girl
yeah it's they're the only ones who
matter weirdly tunnel vision for going
to such a large school
the big twist of number three is that
there aren't flynn brothers there's just
one whoa like a tyler durden situation
like lee's just been imagining this like
violent alter ego yeah
all right keep going stop giving away
these ideas
[Music]
but rule nine says relatives are off
limits so no kissing his older brother
noah
while he has to keep his hands off her
dad and little brother
but rules are made to be broken and
sparks will fly
when elle gets trapped in her very first
abusive relationship
is he violent check
[Music]
blames the victim natch wearing a skirt
like that
he's asking for it still he's freakishly
tall
and she got boobs over the summer so
climb that red flag girl
just get a burner phone and memorize the
exits to a sex gazebo
so creepy get so hot
well this next gazebo is its own thing i
found their
height difference to be crazy i can't
believe they cast
somebody with like a three foot high
difference between them
and they found these very aggressive
ways of
of getting over that like where to kiss
her he's like
there's a lot of her like jumping into
him there's like they do that beat a few
times to kind of cover
how weird it is for him to like have to
lean over it's so
it's like a ichabod crane like full like
she's on her tiptoes and he's like
uh that see they hide it there that's
not what it usually looks like yeah no
she's standing on something there
she's not yeah she's not a tom cruise
number of apple boxes
or they might have done the thing that
tom cruise has to do sometimes where
they actually have to dig like a canal
where his co-star is going to walk so
they're below
and that's the craziest thing about him
is they did that's like that's how huge
that's him
he's all he's in he's already in the
canal
he's andre sized man let's see jacob
lordy
height six five and uh
jody king uh is
five four so yeah that's a
big mismatch yeah i didn't like it i
like it um
i found it weird anyways keep going
tall and she got boobs over the summer
so climb that red flag girl
just get a burner phone and memorize the
exits to a sex gazebo
so creepy yet so hot
hormones will rage thanks to their high
school blindfolded kissing crew
which isn't just a gross idea that
should get the entire school
administration can
[Music]
it's also the biggest cliche in teen
fiction since the popular girl clique
who just wants to start drama
oh they do that one too how about a get
to wasted in table dance scene
a big prom night finale
oh a team jacob love triangle in the
sequel you have no business talking to
me
really but why don't you just throw in a
dramatic run through the airport
sequence for good measure
it's cliches all the way down people
this film exists for one reason
and one reason only
[Music]
wait who's filming him
so hungry he isn't a teenager in the gym
and somebody's just like yeah bro i'm
sweating
like you and me were best friends and
that's all
um this scene was also
this is when i knew part two was just
going to break me
like the scene where this girl's like
trying to get her in trouble
and so notices that the pa system has
been turned on and gets her running
commentary on this weird workout vid
the guy posted it just was so strange to
me
yeah and then so maybe it goes like from
zero to it i was like who are you
who are you a woman yeah she's she's
very happily in a relationship but she
goes from like
zero to like a thousand on the horny
charts when when she sees this video
she's like
yum.com here i go it's it's also like
she's being funny like that i feel like
that wouldn't be like hugely humiliating
that'd be like
people would think that was cool right
that'll be kind of funny like
there are a few times in these movies
where i think people do things that
would be like that would be
celebrated by teenagers but it's treated
like oh the deep shame
i took my shirt off i kissed that boy
in front yeah like okay you look like a
dude your class is hot like that's
normal behavior well i did like that
everyone was chanting his name by the
end of it they were going marco
morgan okay girl that did
that the you taste like a burger i don't
like you anymore girl at the party in
the first one
yes yes okay he's the girl that that was
making out with
noah when uh elle interrupted them at
the party
i figured she was like a like a
transient she looks she does not look
like a high schooler
she i fear she just also looks like
she's definitely in her like mid-20s
she looks like a runaway like like scab
punk kid yeah she looks like she
probably fronts like a death metal band
weirdly the giant boy
he's 35 i think one of the youngest ones
i think he's like
22. the giant boy actor or the giant boy
i'll have to look that up again but i
think yeah yeah no that's the one
saving gray like this movie would be
really weird and inappropriate if these
were real
teenage actors like the one saving grace
is that these are all people in their
twenties and you can feel okay about
them these yeah it would be brilliant if
they
if someone had wet hot american summer
day and it was all
40 year olds oh it was like 10 15 15.
like 40 year olds playing dude that
would be great yes uh
doing the remake that's what i think
also anybody watching this if you're not
watching i know pin 15 on hulu does not
seem like it's a breakout hit
as far as i can tell but it's amazing
everybody
okay um all right let's keep going
wait who's filming him
so settle in for some good old-fashioned
zoomer escapism
where everyone is pretty finds love gets
into harvard
and pays their way with dance dance
revolution tournament winnings
but at the end of the day so the dance
dance revolution of the second one
uh which they take is like a just a
little blip in in
episode one and really expand on it in a
second is
is a thread that is pulled through both
movies that we just never really explore
like the whole point of the kissing
booth is to fund
the dance club that we literally don't
think we ever see
in either movie we never see the dance
club that's there's no stakes because
the only
reason the kissing booth even exists is
to raise money for the dance club
doesn't even matter that's not even in
the story the only time she dances is
ddr
the money raised with the underage
kissing booth goes straight to
wayfair.com or whatever weird
uh money laundering situation is
happening there because there is no
dance club
there's no dance two movies they had a
second chance to be like okay well now
we need to figure out how the dance club
plays it
nope still though but they did find a
way to have this all
hinge on winning a 50 000 prize
uh for a ddr couples competition which
i assume marco uh just gave to her
entirely out of the goodness of his
heart because she's the one who needs
the money well he's making so much money
playing guitar
he's busking at the third street
promenade
at the santa monica mall doing like
gypsy kings b-sides
yeah okay here's my other question uh
is there currently a big
popular video game tournament that's
based around an
arcade game
street fighter has always had a
resilient uh east you know kind of
competition
uh but even still you play that at home
mostly right yeah
but no not like skee-ball you know like
no like korean people
this is like a arcade like you have to
have the pads to practice like this is
not a
guys are getting good at it at their
house how amazing would it have been if
it was starcraft and not ddr
oh that'd be great much already i'm
enjoying this movie much much more if
she's just like
my question and i don't want to belabor
on it too long because this question
involves these being good okay
but if the if the conflict is the
brothers
and it seems like according to every
other character but them it is
why is there a new love interest at all
like shouldn't the sparks be flying
between her and the boy she actually
grew up
ddring with and the older brother should
now be jealous of the ddrs
i think it's that uh they didn't want
part two
to change the story like where part one
ended
is where they need part three to pick up
so
this had to just be filler this is just
two hours
part two is over two hours long and pure
filler everything ends up exactly in the
same way are you calling this the age of
ultron of kissing
it's beyonce we
met quicksilver and scarlet witch in age
of ultron there's nothing on on that
i'll try and left some dangling threads
for uh
accords only happen because of the
foundation laid in age of ultron
everything is settled by the end of this
except she got into berkeley and harvard
oh no
but that could have happened at the end
of the first one too there's no
we didn't need a whole movie to get us
there man
i hope the people who are watching this
have seen the kissing booth because if
not
man good what a lot of patience you have
to listen to us talk about this
spoilers guys spoilers for spoilers
i've got to assume that there are a lot
of angry people uh
that we are more energized talking about
the kissing booth than we were
firefly much more yeah firefly we were
like it's all right yeah you know
they're in space kind of cheap but fun
you know
i'm like what about the dance club
[Laughter]
but at the end of the day they're still
relatable because sometimes they fall
down go boom
in what may be two garbage films with
horrible messages
but if they made movies out of the
cringy stuff you wrote at 15
well i'm still taking offers for ninja
viking versus boo police
netflix give me a call not an investment
lifetime girl never gonna happen
limited series come on you fluffed this
king
simpin ain't easy i did not hit her it's
[ __ ]
i did not oh highly paycheck in pink
melted plastics 30 and 30
so many george
shorts are still cool are they marco oh
would you call that many jorts at john
cena of jorts that was a
john cena
i think i think once we've established
the cena as a unit of jort measurement
we've even exceeded one and a half yeah
i think we're at one and a half
scenarios
i went through this is where you're
wearing jorts on your arms
right full body jord uh i went back and
uh there were scenes where she's wearing
jorts that i didn't include because you
just didn't get a good enough clear
enough
look at the george that's the jordan but
she's still clearly
jordan so i just wanted to throw it up
there just so everybody knows
this is this is a sample this is just
the best visual examples of jorts
thank you lon thank you for your service
anyways keep going
gorge teenagers
marco always has the last word
congratulations
green shot yes rachel
i love just the way they shot her and
dressed her is like
like a long-suffering housewife like
she's also supposed to be 15 but she's
always
like cardigans like a like a floral
print dress and just like
oh lee you've come it also is like it's
the thing where
the parents don't exist where it's
always the kids who answer the door
and like the kids who answer the phone
and stuff like that it's like a charlie
brown
universe where the picture was like
off-screen
it's also weird that they gave a they
gave the not the protagonist
their own baxter baxter
or like like the right the show if the
movie was about
yeah i get him dating her and secretly
being in love with
um going king but you know
i really don't i still feel like i don't
know like is lee
genuinely in love with joey king or is
it more just like
he feels weird about her being with his
brother the story would make so much
more sense if he was
i think right but i think it's crazy
never acknowledge this weird unresolved
tension
throughout the whole yeah you would
think one time they've got to like
establish there's chemistry there
besides just like they're goofy
yeah nope i think based relationships
the the reveal that i want in three is
that because
there's also since if there's no
chemistry between him and and
joey king and there's no chemistry
between him and poor rachel
uh i think the revealing one and three
is that he's gay and just
extraordinarily like debilitatingly ocd
and that's where i why there's so many
controlling rules because he just has to
have them
uh rule number 40 is you have to knock
five times uh before
best friend conversations can start okay
that's the only wheel that makes sense
to me yeah uh
yeah total psycho uh i think he's got uh
l's he he's got previous l's in his
basement
oh they're gonna turn her into a lamp
[Laughter]
i think joey can like we're being really
hard on on joey king she's great like
she was really good in the act like i've
seen her be good in things
i just think this yeah this is just like
slap sticky
this kind of thing is just maybe not her
forte like i feel like the material
let her down but i don't want this to be
interpreted as like i think joey king is
great
in the first draft of this that was can
we just
let her get to the i'm making cool stuff
right the perfect career because yeah
she's super talented like i do feel like
joey king is gonna go on to do great
stuff
and like we'll all look back on this is
like remember those kissing booth movies
yeah i heard i think that these kissing
booth movies are like the reason why
she's going to be
like a mega story right but in the same
way that we do with like
our pets where it's like remember
twilight you know sure
sure because these things and something
we didn't touch on is like
i think loki the reason that these got
so popular
is because like joey king was and jacob
and lordy were dating
like they were actually like a couple
and that became
that made them like instagram famous and
then like oh well you need to see the
movie that these two people that you
follow
are smooching in and it's like that is
the the movie the stuff around the movie
that made it such a phenomenon
so that'll be the next trailer
we should do trailers for instagram uh
all right keep going
real celebrity relationships yeah
rachel rachel and i never wanted to be a
freaking marshmallow in their first life
and this old man on patrol
checking the sex gazebo
[Music]
pause that's the other thing that this
movie
has um weird issues with is it's
sex and making out in weird places like
a downpour
in a gazebo or uh the hollywood sign
which not not that the way it's depicted
in this movie
that's not how you could not spend the
whole night
into the morning soaking in the
afterglow right under the hollywood sign
that's like
insecurity like you would it's also like
freezing cold up there
yeah it's not like coyotes
and it's a tough hike like you would not
emerge from that hike
uh um all clean with your makeup done
like that's not where you want to go for
your first time unless you just want to
be real swampy tired and cranky
yeah it's not it's not as romantic as
depicted not here
also uh just to go back to the old man
in the gazebo
uh what a shame that rip torn is no
longer with us
how amazing would he have been in that
role he would have killed that role
i was thinking maybe harvey keitel you
know he could
i mean i think he says that it's his
spot that he takes girls but like that
guy has definitely watched
uh noah
this is this is part of the context of
the film that yes
he's repeatedly caught noah out there
with various ladies
yeah he's always keeping one eye out
yeah so
i i would look for more big things from
this guy he's uh
he's great even the role that all the
leader scene where a giant teen
tries to bring a girl to the gazebo and
noah shows up and it's just like
this is my spot all right keep going
[Music]
not another teen movie until you've
learned your lesson
does everyone in this movie delete their
text history shady
yeah quite shady um i know we don't have
delayed scenes but
i know the other tag was about the the
teacher reading
magazine which i got i got so obsessed
with this i i replayed that scene like
four times
so there's a scene in a classroom where
they're like taking a test or something
and you pan over to the teacher
and he's reading beekeeper magazine
which immediately
this is this guy my attention because
they always make jokes in high school
movies about what
losers the teachers are outside of class
like tina fey and mean girls really
leans into this
uh and i thought like i guess that's one
of those jokes but it's actually an
interesting backstory to give him like
this this offbeat
hobby like that makes him seem
interesting not like a nerd but
then you you see the actual cover of the
magazine and i believe it's a photo of
the actor
of the actor he made the cover of the
magazine he's reading because he made
the cover
that's the only that's the only reason i
voted against that tag because i
i was really looking and i was like i
think that guy's goatee is different
um a photo i'm not swearing up and down
but
the fact that it was so close maybe
they're like is the implication that
this guy made the cover of beekeeper
magazine
in that case make the movie about him
yeah this year it's not anything
else because i uh i i looked up
just like i searched kissing booth on
twitter today and
like someone was sharing vines where
people were reacting to the beekeeper
magazine so
oh good okay okay oh okay i'm glad the
kids at least got
got noticed that and i i also part of me
feels like
i really hope that's from the original
story
that the 15th they had a side story much
like the little
like mr phelps loved beekeeping and read
beekeeper magazine religiously like just
that
would make me feel good i think that
they they they also
that reminds me of the i guess probably
course correction that
she made because the entire first movie
is like completely white and completely
straight and that where they do the the
gay romance that
like they're largely silent the entire
time it's like a silent film about two
right about two guys like slowly uh
getting into each other you get one
scene where one of the guys who doesn't
appear to really know
elle previously like just kind of breaks
it all down
for her on the beach and otherwise it's
just they just
pause the movie for scenes of like of uh
of like longing looks to each other
while they're doing
you know the field day or whatever they
do those are exclusively gay moments
they peppered it in with exclusively gay
but like
not necessarily speaking roles for those
guys
so good for them uh i guess it's part of
an overall attempt to be like
the kissing booth may seem problematic
but actually
it's great like they kind of we're
threading that through like it's
bringing these kids together
because reasons okay movie whatever you
say
anyways thank you guys for watching so
long and so hard
uh into this video um please subscribe
if you haven't already and hit the like
button and hit the bell so you never
miss
another kissing booth breakdown because
you bet we will be back for kissing
booth three
four five we're gonna skip six then
we're gonna go hard on seven
six is gonna be like halloween three
where it's all different characters in a
different school another big oh god no
back back back
the kissing booth came from the druids
it's gonna be great uh no outtakes uh as
mentioned but we do have some comments
that you guys have
submitted so let's go through some of
these um the holy night of youtube oh i
wanna be thy name
uh asks do they see live chat uh
no i mean i can't speak for you guys i
have a i have our
our own faces open and i have i do have
a browser open
but i have it's just the google tabs for
kissing booth in italian
jacob allordy height and ddr tournament
winnings
yeah i mean i guess that would make
sense to keep the youtube channel open
so i could see comments come in but i do
not do that i'm just i feel like that
would do a weird audio thing
or like i'd hear myself you could keep
the you could keep the music
just watch too distracting i'm sorry
maybe joe will look at it joe
do you look at him i'm too scared to
have anything else open else i'd be
booted from
the show well there you go ryan is
watching though and he plucks
uh he plucks the best of it and and
poops it uh in front of us in the chat
so
we get to see we get to see your
questions um james bond asked for joe
why do you have magnus mustache
i'm not sure what magma's mustache is
but why do you have it
because it's good
uh well there you go yeah free mustache
rides people um sesame frass writes i
feel personally attack spencer i'm 5 3
and my husband is 6'4
i'm sorry i i look love conquers all
i'm just saying like when you cast a
movie you know you have you don't
you have the choice to uh to not fall
into that uh thing we're gonna make a
stepladder
what's that bunk of that mountain yeah i
can't climb that mountain exactly
sam carranza writes uh one is a
reasonable length two develops its
characters more
in both the best and worst ways hmm it
does not do that
um sorry sir it is longer
more things develop but they don't
develop the characters they just kind of
develop
yeah uh and care moon writes the author
was like 17 when she wrote the first but
the rest are from this year and she's 25
so she can be held responsible for this
oh okay good all right
good that makes me feel better okay yeah
i believe there's an ella spin-off
coming out about a beach house
oh good and then you get the whole thing
from a yearbook guys perspective that's
the next book
i hope it works on the lake house rules
where they'll be able to send letters to
one another across time that would be a
good addition
oh great yeah i love that and finally
ben zeitung writes all these characters
look so very unlikable and shallow how
is this movie so popular
i do think it's because of the the show
outside of the show you know it's the
it's the followings that they have and
the real romance that they had going on
behind the scenes
and like jacob laurie was dating zendaya
and like they're
they're they're just cute teens you know
living a life that
cute teens want to live so you want to
watch them do whatever it's not because
the movie's good
it's also popular in the age of netflix
it's so different like would this movie
have been a huge
hit if it was theatrical and people had
to go pay money and go to a theater to
watch it like who knows maybe
but the fact is like if you like other
movies in this genre
netflix stuck it in front of your face
for a few weeks and like yeah
you know maybe you click play you know
like i don't our evaluation of what is
like a massive worldwide
hit now is like so off from where it
used to be even five years ago
yeah i don't know it's kind of hard to
say how big a phenomenon the kissing
booth is really like i don't know
as a parent i can't imagine anyone going
more than taking their kids more than
once to see this
that's for sure maybe two i mean my god
like
what a commitment it's like zack
snyder's kissing booth geez
why does it need to be over two hours
release
the kissing please please no um
all right well that was fun you guys
beating people to death in that one
uh i had a good time uh and yet i know
that we'll be back talking more kissing
booth uh so thank you for joining me
thank you for joining us uh audience and
please come back next week
uh where we'll be discussing a movie
where
hmm that's gonna be too obvious uh
we won't be monkeying around
next week um and we'll see you then
that's what you're getting thanks for
joining us
see you next time bye
[Music]
you